claude moine alias schmoll alias eddy
mitchell est au casino de paris
il est remis de son angine qui lui avait
cassé la voix lors du premier concert et
ils renouent donc sur la scène avec la
scène après six ans d'absence
marie-claire gotti avant j'avais your
mom et et les voitures dans les rues
avec deux haut parleurs quoi bon on
passe à la télé j'ai tout donné mais pas
ça non pourquoi
mais parce que l'on a l'impression de
charmed a retapé du service après vente
côté coulisses où péter scène il ne
mâche pas ses mots notre crooner
comédiens présentateurs de charme
pas de quartier pour la télévision le
cinéma exception faite de sa vocation
comme il dit ce qu'il préfère chanter le
choix que je m'amuse à présenter une
émission de cinéma soit un petit écran
via la télé c'est drôle en tous les cas
le palace de beaumont-sur-oise célèbre
grâce à la dernière séance entame plus
rieuse mans une deuxième carrière
réaction à chaud on a fait des salles
aussi ridicule oui à la balle jaune une
très belle salle pas moins grande salle
de spectacle on en a fait des petites
salles ridicule les gens sont venus chez
eux devant leur télé donc il faut savoir
ce qu'il veut le faire si l'aja est
aussi le côté l'exploitant quand il
vient pleurer faut savoir aussi que
c'est aussi de faire de l'argent et
quand il a cassé une belle salle pour en
faire trois minable faut pas qu'ils
pleurent aujourd'hui vous parler de la
télé mais bien mais là tu es football
j'aime bien pour les infos pour la météo
autre chose comme ça je suis bon je
prenne un peu vous en fait quand même
oui mais moi je fais j'ai pas
l'impression de faire de la télé
justement ce que je leur présente deux
films différents
non mais je parle de la télé en général
- ventos et vous pensez par exemple à
vous sacrifier à quoi mention promotion
pour annoncer que on est con on est
complet qu'on fera donc
un spectacle supplémentaire au zénith le
12 décembre sinon quel intérêt